did you watch Napoleon I did how'd you
like it m I didn't watch it a damn you
lied I didn't watch it you were lied
speak speak up no I want you guys to
watch it and then we'll talk I'll give
you an opinion on it like yeah I would
love that I honestly I think it was mid
that [__] was mid yeah yeah why is
that historical inaccuracies like what
um he never fired a cannon at the
pyramids oh I read that article
too so I was reading the article cuz you
know we were talking I was like I want
to get a Napoleon expert on here to talk
about Napoleon one I'm like
fascinated um but two it'd be really
cool if there is a massive interest in
Napoleon because of the movie yeah so
like you know Hamilton comes out
everybody gets into Hamilton it's like
I'd like to you know learn a little bit
more about this historical figure I'm
hoping this had the same effect because
Napoleon is an incredibly important
historical figure right globally
important not just on some French [__]
like change the world yeah uh uh not the
shape of the pyramids didn't do that but
Ridley Scott is that his name yeah uh I
guess let us uh to believe he did um
Thor thoroughly love the
movie oh
really how you like how they depicted
Napoleon like would you say like you're
like
Napoleon [__] in my [__]
game yeah nah oh okay cuz he was on top
rabbit [__] wasn't he oh really he
was kind of a rabbit [__] wait do you do
they see sexy yeah oh can you tell us
about the movie putting it down nah he
was just a super cuck in the movie bro
like just a Ultra cuck like just just a
simping for this little [__] who's he
hey hey giving it up yo why were you
saying that what that I'm like him what
was that I was trying to see that's
really insulting I believe that you
watch trying you to trap yourself see
you trying to trap me I trying I thought
you were trying to hurt my feelings
right there I still kind of feel put it
down from the bottom son with the you
put it come on reacted when he saw the
paparazzi is it exactly how I Rea stop
guys stop which one of y'all paid the
[__] Paparazzi nobody paid the
paparazzi dude and I thought it was fake
until they asked you what you thought
about the fights and I was like this
[__] Paparazzi out here for
Andrew M we ain't talking about this yet
right no think we did on patreon maybe
patreon I swear one of y'all set that
[__] up no I did not you shorty loves
you bro she called the paparazzi hello
Paparazzi how that even you can hire
[__] like that this is this is what they
got those after asking you guys this is
what I think
uh I think the restaurant called oh
and it was the most disappointed
Paparazzi there was like one Flash and
then a slower one and then it was like
the [__] are we doing
doing did we see the photos anywhere
they only took pictures of you we walked
out and they were like
hold wait for it wait for it so they got
digital memory cards there's no finite
amount of film but they were like don't
don't don't waste memory on these guys
we this was at my uh my 40th birthday uh
my wife and my lovely friends through a
great 40th birthday at an awesome uh
restaurant in the city and it was a lot
of fun and when we walked out much to
our priz there were Paparazzi Alex
walked in and out three times you saw
that just so he could get his his pick
off I saw you change outfits the pit was
fire he forgot something inside say hold
you guys be here in two minutes I had to
get one with the jacket off jacket on
you know go to priz pi.com use a promo
code Schultz don't match your initial
entry of $100 up to that $100 so you put
100 they're going to match up to 100
exactly that's beautiful you said that
better than me now listen we in this
together we're Team okay we are teams go
to priz pick.com get that 100% deposit
match up to $100 with the promo code
Schultz SZ you got this okay now let's
get back to the show